[Music]
you really think Kim Kardashian isn't a
feminist listen I don't know Kim other
than the superficial hello how are you
so you can never it's just my instinct
is that she isn't I don't think because
she takes her clothes off and is
confident with that that that makes you
a feminist that makes you confident and
it makes you business but it doesn't
naturally go with being a feminist what
would what do you think makes you a
feminist somebody who is strong who
self-supporting and who is any guy you
can come up with and that is in all
areas you want to be equal to that man
and I don't need that man to fix my sink
I don't need a man to do this and do
that for me I stand on my own feet I do
it myself but you've gotta be smart some
people may say that that is her I mean
she's built an empire out of I mean I
know it was a sex tape but she's built
an empire but then what do you say that
if he's speaking of the sex tape is just
as much Ray J's the fame as her fame
yeah and and I think that's the concern
you have in applying sexualized nudity
to feminism yeah well you can make that
leap but I just don't think that's what
it wasn't meant to be and the young girl
seeing that we don't want to empower
that by saying that is a brand of
feminism because everybody doesn't
succeed you're right I don't I don't
think that there's anything wrong in
what she does there's nothing wrong at
oh but because you strip off doesn't
mean that you're a feminist I think also
being a feminist means am i running my
life not in order to garner the male
gaze right are all my moves about
getting that so I think it's about
getting power without that I think where
it gets tricky when someone is doing
things where you
think it's related to that it can sort
of muddy the water a little bit yeah but
I do think in terms of the Empire she's
built and being a strong woman she is to
be commended for all that
[Music]
Oh